[Music]
I come you don't laugh n ain't you got
something to make you just
[Music]
smile my sister and I ain't seen her in
years you know if you ain't going to
laugh you need to sell your footy
bone
I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me have
one
heart how come you so nice don't know
maybe you too
nice you seem like trouble I come here
out of
respect but if there ain't nothing to
get that sure ain't nothing to
[Music]
get now got your
attention here what you man need to hear
drink
something P the button there going to be
some change is made
me you got to stand
up
I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we're going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us this time i' be free from
you and enter into creation I die before
I let that happen good that's just the
going away present I've been
needing baby baby baby
[Music]
what do you got to do time for you to
see the world P the
button sweet and loving
[Music]
God